et moi les images du front ukrainien
sont devenus rares ces dernières
semaines mais celle-ci nous sont
parvenues du village de clichyfka repris
dimanche par les forces ukrainiennes
après le président ukrainien félicité
publiquement ses trous
je tiens à rendre hommage au soldat qui
rentre à l'Ukraine ses territoires étape
par étape dans le secteur de barmut à
Clift shifka bravo
en plus de clichyfka deux autres
villages ont été libérés près de la
ville dévastées de parkmouth sur le
front-est robottiné dans le Sud et
andreveca plus à l'est
selon les autorités ukrainiennes les
forces de qui elles font repris 2 km² au
cours de la semaine écoulée dans la
région de barmut et plus de 5 km² dans
le sud sur ces images le village
complètement détruit dans drifta libérée
du contrôle militaire russe en fin de
semaine dernière tous ces bourses qui ne
comptaient que quelques centaines
d'habitants avant la guerre pour les
plus peuplées ont été complètement
détruits par les combats engagés depuis
juin dans une difficile contre-offensive
face aux lignes fortifiées russes les
forces ukrainiennes tentent d'accentuer
la pression ces dernières semaines avant
l'arrivée de l'hiver